The CW certainly knows its brand, and the
company is shooting right down the middle
with 2018's breakout hit, All American.
The series is a dramatization of the real-life
story of Spencer Paysinger, a star football
player from South Los Angeles who beat the
odds to make it all the way to the NFL, where
he played linebacker for the New York Giants.
Spencer James is the lead character of the
show, based loosely on Paysinger.
His fish-out-of-water story has captivated
audiences from the get-go, earning All American
an early renewal for not just a second season,
but also a third.
"It's the story of an outsider, of a person
who's just trying to find who they are in
this world."
If the fresh-faced young actor portraying
the charismatic safety looks familiar to you,
there's probably a reason why.
Spencer James is played by Daniel Ezra, an
accomplished young actor and veteran of both
the stage and TV.
Let's break down the roles that led him here,
and highlight the projects you might have
seen him in before.
Being an English actor, born in Birmingham
in the West Midlands, Daniel Ezra naturally
kicked off his professional career in British
productions.
He began acting in 2014, making his small-screen
debut in the television movie Murdered by
My Boyfriend.
Ezra then landed a one-off role on the BBC
drama series The Village and the critically-acclaimed
movie Blood Cells in 2014.
In 2016, Ezra scored the role of Dan Johnson
on Undercover, a six-part BBC drama that centers
on a human rights barrister fighting to free
an American inmate from death row.
Fans may also recognize Ezra as Daniel Reed
from season 2 of anthology series The Missing,
or as DC Ashton from the police procedural
Prime Suspect 1973.
That series rolled out in 2017, but for this
young actor, 2018 was the year that changed
everything.
Before he landed the leading role on All American,
Ezra had another memorable TV turn as Nathaniel
Wilson on the British series A Discovery of
Witches.
That show is an adaptation of the popular
All Souls trilogy of fantasy novels by Deborah
Harkness.
The story of the series centers on Diana Bishop,
a historian and witch who discovers an ancient
grimoire in Oxford's Bodleian Library.
This revelation proves unfortunate, as it
draws Diana deeper into a world of magic and
evil creatures that she would prefer to leave
well enough alone.
Ezra's character, Nathaniel Wilson, crops
up in the very first episode as a Daemon computer
whiz with a witch for a daughter.
Although Ezra wasn't listed as a principal
cast member, his character recurred throughout
the first season, and had a memorable impact
on the plot.
It was likely this appearance more than anything
else that got Ezra noticed by casting directors,
and paved the way for his leading role on
All American.
While the football drama is undoubtedly the
27-year-old actor's biggest break to date,
it's fair to say his career got a major boost
from his role on A Discovery of Witches.
Witches was renewed for two more seasons back
in 2018, but there's been no announcement
regarding whether Ezra will return.
We assume the CW is keeping him pretty busy.
Back in 2017, Ezra put his classical training
to use playing Sebastian in the National Theatre's
live performance of Shakespeare's Twelfth
Night.
The gender-bending comedy is one of the Bard's
most famous works, and Sebastian was a solid
role for such a new talent.
The story of Twelfth Night concerns intersecting
cases of mistaken identity; in the play, Sebastian
is the twin brother to Viola.
He's lost at sea in the first scene and presumed
dead by his sister, though it's later revealed
that he survived the shipwreck by clinging
to the mast of his broken vessel.
He's rescued by the sailor Antonio, who ultimately
falls in love with him.
While Ezra's character is off-stage for much
of the play's action, he does return to take
part in the comedy's amusing conclusion.
Twelfth Night gave Ezra the chance to cut
his teeth performing live theatre for a TV
audience - an opportunity that any young actor
would certainly relish.
So next time you see him chasing a receiver
as Spencer James, remember that the dude can
also do Shakespeare.
"I'm just playing.
Come on, dog."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.